il tourne détruit à quel point au point
de vouloir mourir des brimades des
insultes voire des violences physiques
chaque jour des élèves sont victimes de
harcèlement scolaire
il sentait comment le matin quand dieu
il fallait aller à l'école stressé
angoissé
parce que j'ai je me disais qu'est ce
qui est le harcèlement à l'école
un fléau médiatisé à partir du début des
années 2000 l'une des premières à faire
c'était en meurthe et moselle pendant
trois mois
sébastien lycéens à longwy a été le
souffre douleur de trois autres élèves
s'y déroulera une date - cliff qu'ils
avaient chauffé chez les mots que nous
marteau qui m'ont mis d'autres cas de ce
genre suivront pour y faire face
des actions sont mises en place en 2008
dans ce collège parisien une équipe
éducative se réunit à la moindre alerte
de harcèlement elle est composée d'une
assistante sociale
le professeur et d'une infirmière est
pas le bouc émissaire est toujours celui
qui est différent et plus fragiles
entendu nous on doit travailler avant
que l'élève devienne un bouc émissaire
et du côté de la classe politique elle
tarde à s'emparer du problème il faut
attendre 2011 et les assises nationales
contre le harcèlement scolaire
pour que le sujet soit prise en compte
luc chatel alors ministre de l'éducation
nationale lance une série de mesures
parmi elles la formation des enseignants
dès le primaire et la médiation entre
élèves
il ya 10% d'enfants qui sont victimes de
brimades avec des conséquences parfois
dramatiques ça peut aller jusqu'à un
échec scolaire
ça peut aller sur ce graphe disque et
difficultés psychologiques voire même
jusqu'au suicide des campagnes de
sensibilisation sont lancés 2012
un premier numéro vert et créer autre
initiative la mise en place d' élèves
ambassadeurs dès 2015
ces lycéens ou collégiens viennent
sensibiliser leurs camarades sur le
harcèlement scolaire
à leurs côtés les professionnels chargés
de les accompagner
le fedora des ambassadeurs et ça nous
permet d'avoir des relais au sein même
de l'établissement pour que puissent
sensibiliser leurs camarades avec leurs
propres mots et le message est beaucoup
plus percutant lorsqu'il est donné par
des élèves auprès de leurs camarades que
plutôt pas des adultes en 2019 dix mille
de ses élèves était ambassadeur mais
selon une étude de l'unesco
près de 30 % des collégiens et lycéens
français ont été victimes de harcèlement
en 2018
[Musique]